le monde s'excuse aujourd'hui on se
retrouve à l'ancienne avec un certain
mika et hugo sur un mode murder leur
tour leur tour du silence aussi est ok
on aurait fait ce secret c'est mickaël
murder et des passages secrets c'est le
mordor je vous dise elikia mais j'vous
dit exprimer car derrière je peux courir
si je suis murder story durera trois ans
gars vous avez été un fan a pas me
croire sérieusement cet accord s'est pas
passé d'accord mais pas chez moi y'a pas
sasha grey diego c'est devenu tout noir
d'internet
pourquoi il fait noir bâbord
ok ok j'ai vu marc deleury de trois ans
merde [ __ ] jetaient pas j'ai pas je
suis sensible à j'en ai marre c'est hugo
c'est hugo liard il arrive pas de boîte
pourquoi tu viens pas égaux tel quel
mais tout ce dont a pâti tout seul dans
la maison cours montent à tort des mois
j'ai reçu la porte en a bon qu'il peut
pas j'ai cassé ma les messieurs je
voudrais c quitte à retarder ou tata
pound et leurs hangars tin tuc assez
partagés cas c'est le cas tu fais quoi
on est peut-être là qu'est ce qui se
passe
bats toi c'est lui quoi je suis pas tuer
et non à la magouille
on a du mal
binder aller voilà chez waste and c'est
mika sur ma vie c'est me casser ces
mythes ya et je te jure fais moi
confiance tullow [ __ ] aux noms n'ont
qu'un temps et ouvert ouvert avec moi
c'est pas moi mais j'étais collé à toi
quoi voici dix mètres mais brugot voilà
rigolait bien le km5 attend que ça ferme
sa gueule merci c'est qu'il a mal fait
et attaque la mauvaise personne assez
mis cas d'accord la santé moi tout seul
et c'est à cet art à je te jure que cet
art un vase icône le voilà donc plus
tard à ma patrie je t'aime et je suis
désolé c'est parce que gm prend soin de
mes amis est banale et alors du coup tu
fais quoi pedrina tu paies tous et non
pas toi t'es pris pour un sparta à la
barricade énorme de sparte applique à
tous explique qu'on voit sur toi quotas
voilà microgen protège we love you so
much love you like a love song baby i
love you should read a entassé je
t'embrasse
non mais je voulais pas qu il y avait
une fougère des voix c'est une mouche
ses salariés bertholet ça ça tu fais ta
cuisine avec un fusil à pompe ou si
c'est ça c'est quoi je vais dire un truc
c'est mika ben si c'est moi c'est
michaela il fait un coup de bluff
non moi je suis là où tu te laisses ou
l'arrêter vous croyez jamais connu
c'est tellement facile de bluff il la
regarde quoi le truc qui fait pour
bluffer c'est un nazi vas-y takkal par
contre au tlv voilà les images me basile
ader à la malaisie alesi a pas de
problème et aux olives astéroïde go
c'est tellement beau cette petite femme
marchera pas allez à bientôt 26 ans tu
fermes ta gueule toi oh [ __ ] quand on
parlait mais programmée et tu prends moi
sortir ton gun l'emploi se referme tout
les cas fait des ricochets des conquois
talent à un personnage est juste un gros
gun oui vous savez parfois que certains
et tartas j'avoue il bien passé là il
est sur l'application de sous toit aux
îles et l'agro et voilà non mais le mec
qui est ancien protégé était une grosse
merde
ah oui tu appelles hugo vas-y tu moi
c'est une mare d'eau ou pas non c'est
ciel comme cecchin ok fkc hugo ok c'est
michael murray lucas c'est pas mieux tu
sais quoi les tic c'est moi c'est que
c'est lui vous avez fait d'avoir toute
la vidéo car c'est évident c'est lui
qu'a tu vois tu vois ego projet
classique avec basit eu l'élection le
taux atteint le qui tue le tue était
hors de cause
je pensais que j'étais gay
j'estime tué parce qu'il est tellement
nul que j'ai fait tout ce que tu as
trouvé ou partie dans le sens vrai
sentiment de bon la pelle la gâchette
lagaf sur l'état et rend sa maille te
fera pas de bisou dessus rien par contre
parfois j'ai tiré dessus les nouvelles
vas-y vas-y et nsg une répartie de peau
l'élu kane a bizarrement tabid et là par
contre le mcs en violet c'est le plus
suspect très bien et je suis fait comme
cha ou suspects au fait comment réserver
10 mois merde
j'peux comme celui-là on est d'accord et
a par contre tu gagnes tu sais toi mika
d'accord c'est moi y répète et je suis
sur des cartons en train de sauter donc
je vais tuer maintenant voilà c'est quoi
ton jeu via l'intranet ou labello tiens
excuse moi j'aimerais devant d'un petit
article à la place de l'intérieur
éventuellement on peut négocier bien
fort et de plus près laisse-moi toucher
le produit au moins le bonus sera
jusqu'à produire tout ce que produit tu
peux toucher non aujourd'hui je touche
le produit mais là tu vois touché ce
produit et la station la jeune albinos
est vrai les gens c'est à dire fin de
cette vidéo sur guérite moi ça faisait
pas longtemps connaît pas faire un petit
murder j'espère que ça vous a plu
en tout cas se fait toujours autant
plaisir d'être d'être fourbe et vilains
avec ses copains voilà ça c'est une
phrase qui servait à rien sans tomber
dans une nouvelle vidéo merci d'avoir
gardé que tout le monde dit elle devient
folle hockey les témoignages affluent